they arrived by bus tired and hungry
several dozen migrants and asylum
seekers from mostly central and south
american countries arrived over the
weekend to a bus terminal in new york
city they all had one-way tickets and
nowhere to go
they all crossed into the u.s to the
state of texas days earlier
but that state's governor greg abbott
has said that they are overwhelmed by
the recent influx of migrants so he's
bust some of them to immigrant friendly
new york city as a way of saying you
deal with them
but new york's mayor eric adams on
monday blasted abbott saying the city
shelters are unprepared to properly care
for the migrants i don't think anything
is more anti-american
than shipping people on a bus
45 hour trip
without any of the basic needs that they
have a direction or coordination
coordination we have no idea the number
of people we have no idea
of you know where the final destinations
are
he's just totally disregarding of the
human part of this and it's not just new
york in recent days and weeks abbott has
busted an estimated 6 000 migrants to
washington d.c as well a city already
dealing with a homeless crisis
the defense department rejected the
mayor's request for national guard
troops to help deal with the influx of
migrants from texas
abbott is a far-right conservative with
a record of pro-gun and anti-immigration
policies he's currently in a hard-fought
re-election campaign in november while
he says bussing migrants to washington
and new york is only because his state's
social safety net is being strained
others see him as using migrants as
pawns in a dangerous political stunt
as for the migrants in new york many
were desperate
well why did i come here because of the
situation in the country that everyone
knows about because it's difficult to
survive in venezuela there's no medicine
there's no security there's nothing
there is no way to live in peace
as is normally the case with political
battles of immigration in america it's
humans who often get used as pawns this
time in the form of one-way bus tickets
gabriel lozando al jazeera new york